bull rat is this way to enable people to
drop their guard
and reveal what they would stay behind
closed doors
it's much more interesting that the
people that she visits it's much more
interesting if they've really got a good
point so i had to be really really
careful about making sure that every
single person
really had a con a convincing argument i
started off just
jotting down a bunch of memories i had
about like 80 memories
um and and looking at them i could see
the semblance of a story like this
family shows up because the dad
takes this family and just plops them on
this piece of land in the middle of
nowhere and i just needed to figure out
how to
put all the memories in the proper place
to make this work as a story
my prediction is that you'll never see
donald trump
as an on-screen character because he's
simply implausible
as a character you can write heroes you
can write villains but there's no such
thing as an interesting character who
doesn't have a conscience
knowing everything that was leading up
to that night and everything that would
happen within 12 months after that night
it was i could pretty much ascertain if
these guys were to have a debate
if these guys were to talk about what's
on their mind on this given night
what that conversation would entail my
brother and i wrote pages and pages and
pages of sound description you know the
first
two words of the script are he hears
on a camera level we don't show pov
until the end of the movie the whole
movie is poh
it's a point of hearing creating a
character with very strong emotional arc
like ferns that can anchor us allow you
to
you understand what's the emotional
thing in
on very unpredictable environment
suddenly you find yourself
in but you know what you're looking for
that arc has to be very strong
very simple i wanted the audience to be
in an
active position not just to sit and to
watch a story already told
you know try to understand you know i
wanted the father to be
not only a story but an experience and
to play with the feeling of
[Music]
disorientation
i wanted it to be really fun and
interesting and
compelling and that the thriller element
really felt
real and so if it was never going to
work if cassie
you know our lead was going around kind
of
telling people off for doing the wrong
thing it's much more interesting that
the people that she visits
people who maybe had a hand in
the thing that happened in the past it's
much more interesting if they've really
got a good point so i had to be really
really
um honest and really careful
about um making sure that every single
person
really had a con a convincing argument
because otherwise it just seems
too easy i kind of took a break from
filmmaking for a few years
after my daughter was born and i was
just trying to wrap my head around like
the types of films that i might want to
make
moving forward and um
it was around the time that my daughter
reached the
age of the the character of david who
you see in the film
that i was kind of seeing things through
her point of view more
and remembering what it's like to be her
age when we were moving to arkansas
and i also read this book uh by willa
cather
um called my antonia in which she talks
she she writes a story about growing up
on a farm in nebraska and she had
mentioned this quote about
just how much her work took off once she
started to really remember
rather than just admire like admire
other writers
and i kind of felt like maybe i was
doing that in my own work and i felt
inspired to
sit back and try to remember what it was
like
to be a child and to create something
that i could even leave behind for my
daughter
and and that's basically the genesis of
this project i started off just
jotting down a bunch of memories i had
about like 80 memories
um and and looking at them i could see
the semblance of a story like this
family shows up because the dad
uh takes this family and just pops them
on this piece of land in the middle of
nowhere
and then uh by the end you know there's
a fire
and and there's also a patch of minari
that seems to grow the only thing that
seems to really last on this farm
so i kind of felt there's this
interesting through line of a story and
i just needed to figure out how to
put all the memories in the proper place
to make this work as a story
uh erin 2020 has been one for the books
i'm curious
does watching a year like this play out
make you want to write about it and what
would the finale look like
please tell me it won't be revenge of
the murder hornets
uh it wouldn't be if i wrote it uh i
think but
uh listen a lot will be written about
these
uh about these last few years uh by
screenwriters and by playwrights but
uh my my prediction is that you'll never
see
donald trump as an on-screen character
that'll always be off-screen that you'll
see him
on televisions and news footage because
he's simply implausible
as a character uh and i you
you can write heroes you can write
villains but there's no such thing as an
interesting character who doesn't have a
conscience
the sound perspective stuff came very
early
it's like i said that may have been 12
years ago that i kind of
i kind of was dreaming i found myself
dreaming about this cinematic language
but then it was the process of earning
it you know i knew that i knew that i
was
kind of i i had kind of received this
incredibly special
um framework and then it was about
how to earn this on a on a story level
and a character level
and you know it's interesting you say
that that you felt that gut punch
with the silence because what a shocking
idea
that the absence of all sound can be a
gut punch and i think that
as it relates to writing or painting or
all the arts the space between the notes
and music
what is that what is it about the
absence how do you earn
the absence we my brother and i wrote
pages and pages and pages of sound
description
that didn't even make it into the film
but just so we understood it i mean
didn't make it to the final script
much of it is there but but really
that's about you know the first
two words of the script are he hears
you know and you're and that's before
you see the picture
he hears and then you come to picture
and and the whole shape and the last
line of the script
the first two words of the last line are
he sees
and so you move there's a very simple
arc to that
because we actually don't show on on a
camera level we don't show pov
until the end of the movie the whole
movie is poh
it's a point of hearing so it's really
so it's really written
from that point of hearing and very
diligently so
shaka you you almost humanized
the agent miller um in the
in in the script and in the film you
know can you tell us
about about doing that about
i mean i'm not saying it's a i think
it's a terrific uh
choice but can you tell us about
humanizing
miller well i mean i think it's more so
one of the things we discovered
um was that this guy had investigated
the
freedom writers murders in uh
mississippi
and so it was just fascinating to us
that he
you know years apart was investigating a
clan
and then you know years later was tasked
with
dismantling the illinois chapter of the
panthers i thought there was a real
opportunity there to um
just so just show the complexity of
really you know white centrism is an
ideology
you know what i mean like this is a guy
who you know he thinks he's doing the
right thing
uh in a lot of ways and you know he
i think it's it's been interesting to
sort of watch how different viewers
view that character like we were really
fortunate in that before the pandemic
happened we had a screening with like
six black you know audience members and
six white audience members
and their their reads of that character
were fascinating
um because you know a lot of the white
audience members were like
well i he didn't seem like you know to
be that bad of a person i was wondering
like when he made the shift was
you know our black audience members were
like what are you talking about he
compared the panthers to the clan
and that told me everything i needed to
know about him right then and there
on that day there was a march
of many members of the upper class in
england to
protest the right to hunt foxes and i
thought oh
these are great targets and
i went undercover as i think borat was
from moldova at that point he had a
different name
but again it was the same it was more
for satirical aim because i was going to
go in my country we uh hunt the jewels
and we give them
you know 30 minutes and then we chase
after them would you do that here
and we would go well i suppose well um
how many if it was 30 minutes and it was
fair then you know i suppose so if it
was sportsman
you know and then i realized at that
point
oh bull rat is this way to enable people
to drop their guard
and reveal what they would say behind
closed doors
because they felt that this was never
going to be on british tv i'm curious
how was it liberating to take the story
from stage to screen did you find that
you were able to open it up
was it daunting i mean how did that work
for you
what i didn't want to do is just to film
a play because you know i think it's
it's not very exciting it's not
challenging i wanted to do something
very cinematic so i kept the narrative
of the play because i think that it was
what was original about it which is
to try to tell the story from the inside
and to put the audience in a very
unique position as if they were trying
to go through a labyrinth trying to
figure it out trying to understand
what is going on in a way i wanted the
audience to be in an active position
uh not just to sit and to watch a story
already told you know
try to understand and as if they were
experiencing
something you know i wanted the father
to be not only a story but an experience
and to play with the feeling of
disorientation because it's about
a man losing his bearings it's about
dementia
and i wanted the audience to experience
away
as if they were losing their own
bearings and
and so it was a way for me to play with
the feeling of disorientation and i
thought it was very cinematic
but again i wanted to do something that
the cinema can do
and that only the cinema can do and i
think you just
kind of struck this extraordinary
balance of like
spontaneity and preparation um
that just like set a new standard in my
mind for how i want to make
films well thank you and you know it
does start with writing
because because jessica buddha's book
is a collage it's so diverse and so
wide how much she's able to capture
a time in this country for entire
generation of people
uh shifting uh changing their lives and
and so creating a character with very
strong emotional arc
and like ferns that can anchor us allow
you to
find like you know you go to this
beautiful town or
you you know you're in this in a in a
hurricane
you understand what's the emotional
thing
in very unpredictable environment
suddenly you find yourself in but you
know what you're looking for
and your dp knows what you're looking
for your actors know what you're looking
for
that that arc has to be very strong very
simple
um so then you're not just capturing
whatever
out there it's intentional it isn't just
go there
verite everything you know so then when
he shows up there he's like okay i know
where this character emotionally needs
to be
so i'm going to shoot certain way even
though i had all the options in the
world
just just talk a little bit about
putting words in the mouths
because nobody really ever reported
what happened in that room but but but
you had to put words in the mouths of
people we are familiar with
but yet have it be based on fact just
talk
talk through a little bit of that right
i mean the
interesting thing was when i first found
out of course this was a very real night
the night february 25th 1964 when
cassius clay beat sunny liston
he did go back to malcolm's room at the
hampton house
and spend the evening most of the
evening in quiet conversation with
malcolm
jim brown and sam cook and the next
morning is when he announced
that he was in the nation of islam
everyone knows about the relationship
between ali and malcolm x
but sam cook was really the oddball
right there it was like what's he doing
there
and when you started digging into sam
cook you went like
wow this guy was kind of working within
the system
so sam did these very subtle tells
that kind of i think alluded to
the influence of people like malcolm x
and muhammad ali
and jim brown and this idea of like
black self-reliance i like to tell
people
i saw these four men not as the civil
rights movement but as the nascent black
power movement
and that's a key key difference so
no having that information knowing i
just figured
you know knowing everything i know about
these guys when i decided to write it as
a play
knowing everything that was leading up
to that night and everything that would
happen within 12 months after that night
it was i could pretty much ascertain if
these guys were to have a debate
if these guys were to talk about what's
on their mind on this given night
what that conversation would entail and
then from there
it was about okay now let's forget about
them being icons
because the doors are closed so just
like you know
it's like a famous person comes home the
cameras are flashing
they close the doors and they relax
let's be motivated by like
them as human beings them as real people
and
for that element of it you know i took
all the information i had
but then emotionally i just went
honestly kwame i went back to
the same debate that i would have with
my friends at like the freshman
dormitory at howard
you know it's the debate it's the debate
that groups of black men
have been having for god knows how long
you know what i mean it's like when you
talk about you you talk about lincoln
perry and stephen fetch it right
he was both he was one of the first
black millionaires ever known but hey
in order to become a millionaire all he
had to do was perpetuate negative images
of black people
that would affect infect us for
generations we would have
visceral debates about that in college
so it was like i want to bring those
visceral debates
to this play but again once again put
the
put the idea put the words into the
mouths of the guys
who influenced that manner of thinking
whether it be malcolm
holly sam or jim it's a first person
narration the novel
and the way arvin wrote that characters
thoughts were so
specific so funny so insightful
you know kind of wild and so i just knew
it had to be first person narration from
the beginning
i had only done that in the short film
that josh mentioned plastic bag
where verner herzog is the voice of this
bag going on this existential journey
and that was the only time i had used
anything like voice over so
i went back and looked at um kind hearts
and coronets
uh julie jim so back back in that
time period i saw those and then i
jumped forward to
um fight club which i thought was really
interesting because
ed norton's voice over is it's about him
it's his perspective but it's also
sometimes social commentary which
balram's character and the white tiger
has
um it's also kind of funny it's darkly
comic
and then goodfellas wolf of wall street
taxi driver
um goodfellas was really interesting
because it's an epic story
and this is the first time i've ever
dealt with an epic story you have
balram's childhood his time as a servant
and then
three years later when he's a successful
entrepreneur
in bangalore and so
studying those really helped
you